y este gran movimiento de personas que
están trabajando para crear derechos
económicos no ha sido en cono incluyendo
a la salud garantizada mejor educación
mejores salarios y derechos laborales
para todos en eeuu un movimiento que
está luchando por reconocer y reparar
las heridas de la injusticia racial de
la colonización de la misoginia y la
homofobia y proponer y construir e
imaginar sistemas de inmigración y de
política exterior que eviten la
xenofobia y la violencia del pasado un
movimiento que se dé cuenta de la
brutalidad insostenible de una economía
que premia las grandes diferencias de
riqueza para algunos a expensas de la
estabilidad para muchos y que organiza
aquí una campaña de bases para retomar
nuestra democracia en un momento cuando
millones de personas en eeuu están
buscando
sin soluciones sistémicas
al desempleo a la falta de salud y
espíritu del pueblo
y por todos
sanders de vermont para presidente de
estados unidos de américa